blackbirds ever sail on she boasts
impossible yo split nothing black braids
goes but I'd say of the ring in the
photos I suppose if you join and be one
less filthy scandal on this island
wait just a face in pirate Edward Kenway
what did this to me
too much of a coward to finish the job
taken from the neh himself
this was not quite a year ago a merchant
vessel was thank it off the coast I've
kept him chicken salad lining his
pockets
it's a place more men on watch
Zecharia happens you are a criminal I
cheat
your arrogance knows no bounds how do
you turn these negotiations are over
consulate that is my offer two thousand
pounds for the black powder is simply
the cost of doing business in this
economy majesty nothing to you I'm
guaranteed it deal ah Harper will be
defenseless without saying exactly and
that is why the price is to a thousand
pounds the economy when Pirates murder
the village in its sleep the blood will
be on your hands
strike that now that should be your
fault not mine
nobody move these ship is ours that's a
pirate ah da Vinci's honor is worth it
so you're willing to die we're another
man's peridot
and how many are you insane
the hole is full of gunpowder
Romana very Edward let's be the captain
of this pathetic
domination is that captain I can't damn
your fuses do something damage perhaps
we should forgo the weapons and assault
the ship with the wretched stench of
your burning beer offended by a little
stink yeah you're in the wrong
profession
thatch I'm not impressed Oh your men
have been out of gunpowder for a month
their pistols are useless your grenades
are nothing but empty shells and yet we
took this ship without firing a single
shot those sailors were Truffaut we
would've been vastly outgun Edward the
day that I'm forced to use my weapons
will surely be my last good pirates
aren't only fighters they're human we
are the best no the best are always
prepared there are years beyond these
walls stow your doubts before you
inspire the mutiny now let's go and get
that captain
votes I voted against your campus our
ranks I've numbered them three to one
they don't stand a chance
Wow the Pirates tell nothing but lies
their Woodman's juiceless we are His
Majesty's best two arms
I command you do knows that Hey
prove me wrong
Junior fight this Cup
your captain has deceived you friendless
the toil and sweat leave and break your
bones but for a pittance from the crown
and your captain
they vilify us those scoundrels do yet
they rob the poor under the cover of law
while we wonder the rich with the
strength of our kind would you not
better make one of us then sneak after
the asses of these villains for
employment
this is not doing what
or was low-side they said for the vessel
itself our crew was decimated we
suffered a terrible defeat
there was however on victory to be had
at the end of the battle
watching the lifeless corpses other
pirates we captured hang at the gallows
ya rotten stench was a hard line you
have a little thing have you
where's your friend now
we're ice venomous words save your
pitiful ass
but this time I bring something deadly
other words
not quite how I would have done it well
to each their own